CASSIE KOZYRKOV: With over
300 sessions at NEXT 2018,
it's understandable you
couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't see "What's
New with TensorFlow,"
then stay tuned, because
here's the rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So what's TensorFlow?
TensorFlow is a machine
learning framework
that's been used to go
hunting for new planets
and discover solar systems
similar to our own,
prevent blindness by
helping doctors catch
diabetic retinopathy
early, and save rainforests
by alerting authorities to signs
of illegal logging activity.
It's what AlphaGo and
Google's Cloud Vision
are built on top of, and
it's yours to play with.
TensorFlow is open source.
You can download it for
free and get started today.
And we've been working to
make it easier and more
useful than ever before.
Here are some of my
favorite highlights.
Let's start with
TensorFlow Eager.
If you tried TensorFlow
in the old days
and ran away screaming
because it forced
you to code like an
academic or alien
instead of like a developer,
there's great news for you.
TensorFlow Eager Execution
lets you interact with it
like a pure Python programmer.
All the immediacy of writing
and debugging line by line,
instead of holding
your breath while you
build those huge graphs.
Keras plus TensorFLow
equals easier neural network
construction.
If you like
object-oriented thinking
and you like building neural
networks one layer at a time,
I think you'll love tf.keras.
In just these few
lines of code, we've
created a sequential
neural network
with all the bells and whistles.
New languages.
You asked, and we listened.
TensorFlow is not just
for Pythonistas anymore.
It now runs in many languages,
from R to Swift to JavaScript.
And speaking of JavaScript, you
can train and execute models
right in the browser
with TensorFlow.js.
TensorFlow Lite
brings model execution
to a variety of devices,
including mobile and IoT,
giving you more than a 3x
boost in inference speed-up.
Yes, now you can get machine
learning on your Raspberry
Pi or your phone.
See the full talk for a live
demo of image classification
on an Android emulator.
Satisfy your need for
speed with Cloud TPUs.
If you're tired of
waiting for your CPU
to finish churning through
your data to train your model,
you can now get your hands on
hardware specially designed
for the job.
And we've just announced
the V3 TPUs in alpha.
Next, make your input
processing more expressive
and efficient with
the TF.data namespace.
TF.data gives you fast,
flexible, easy-to-use data
pipelines synchronized
with training.
And finally, you can
find and share solutions
on TensorFlow Hub,
which is a repository
for reusable, pre-trained
machine learning model
components, packaged
for one-line reuse,
which is awesome.
So that's it for my
favorite highlights.
If you'd like to
see the full talk,
check out the link in
the description below.
And don't forget to subscribe
to the Cloud YouTube channel
for more great NEXT rewind on
content thanks for watching.